I'll never forget this I opened the door
for a woman in McDonald's we were both
walking right a little head and I opened
it and let her walk through
if I tell you that my mom basically
treated that event like I won the Nobel
Peace Prize
for like three weeks but think about how
smart that is like think about how
reinforcing that played out she really
made me feel special man she really did
it right she just really did a good job
of
making me feel good about the things
that were around my kindness I think
modern day parents and most parents do
not do that I think they focus on dumb
like grades because they are
insecure